it's great to welcome to the program
today Aaron Lasher Aaron is the chief
strategy officer at BRD we are going to
be talking about blockchain technology
we're going to be talking about
cryptocurrency and sort of unwinding a
lot of what has been quite frankly a
little bit concerning to people in our
audience Aaron so we'll get to all that
first and foremost thanks for being here
thank you for having me so let's start
with the crypto space in terms of one of
its but its most sort of publicly
visible aspects which is the value of
some of the larger crypto currencies
Bitcoin litecoin aetherium and others
there's been this sort of crypto winter
over the last year and a half prices of
generally speaking declined although
more recently there's been somewhat of a
recovery question one is can we glean
anything about the future of blockchain
technology and/or cryptocurrency from
the week to week or even month-to-month
price fluctuations or these kind of
separate or only tangentially related
things I would say the latter I think
they're tangentially related the the
history of cryptocurrency prices and
Bitcoin in particular is fraught with
bubbles and busts so in the short term
prices don't tell you a lot about the
long term prospects of crystal dope
currency but if you just look at the
fundamentals then I think that there is
a very bright future for crypto in
general can you talk a little bit about
whether you think that if someone is
trying to sort of evaluate the space you
have on the one hand the major
currencies and you have on the other
hand ICO projects many of which are not
even around anymore many of which
disappear relatively quickly after their
their inception are these different
categories would you categorize projects
and currencies and in some other way or
how should we think about that I think I
think that's a great way to make a split
so you've got these main chain coins
like Bitcoin and aetherium and Bitcoin
cash that you mentioned but then you
have these icos or initial coin
offerings and during 2017 was sort of
the year of I SEOs
now I see Oh tokens are not really
cryptocurrencies with unique properties
rather they're a tokenized version of
some kind of utility and associated with
some kind of project or company so when
you would evaluate one of these coins
you really have to look deep into their
documentation for the plan for the corn
and why it might have value and how it's
going to be used and do what any
investor would do and looking at at any
asset and just try to get a really deep
understanding of how the how the asset
works mechanically so let's focus in a
little bit on not ICO projects that are
tokenizing some utility or other use but
but focusing a little bit on the major
kryptos early on there were a number of
sort of debates about the utility and
the the sort of characteristics that
were pros and cons for crypto currencies
and one of the debates was around is
this at some point going to scale where
you will use Bitcoin to buy a pizza for
example and as we sort of now recognize
a lot of what is going on that has maybe
held down the adoption of some of the
massive Kryptos have been combinations
of difficulty in terms of scalability
because of sort of transactional
limitations as well as transaction fees
that from time to time have gotten sort
of oppressive relative to the
transaction sizes that people have been
looking at so what do you think of the
future of that use of crypto sort of as
a replacement for cash or credit card
transactions for small payments and and
or I guess I would say should we really
be looking elsewhere as far as the
primary utility of a lot of these
currencies it's a it's a it's an open
question and a hotly debated one the the
magic of Bitcoin in the early days was
it did have very low fees and so you
could you could zap it to somebody very
quickly back and forth and get this this
feeling of instantly transferring value
now there are some trade-offs with
having a decentralized currency it's not
as efficient as a centralized database
and
so as these currencies get more popular
and the transaction counts get higher
you have to start looking really closely
at whether to change parameters in the
protocol to accommodate more
transactions accommodate cheaper
transaction fees or to try and preserve
some some level of decentralization and
what we have right now is a lot of
experimentation so Bitcoin had a
contentious split where the community
disagreed on how to scale it and one
side said that we should focus on
keeping it very lightweight for people
who run full nodes I don't want to get
too complicated but I think people
probably know might know what that means
let me know we can can always get
sidetracked and and try to layer in
additional protocols on top of that so
that you can so you can have cheaper
transactions and the other camp said
let's increase the transaction capacity
natively so that's one debate and then
you have other other coins that have
incredible transaction capacity for for
no fees or very cheap fees but they're
really really heavy protocols and so
some of them only have maybe two or
three people maintaining the network
which would be a concern if you wanted
to keep it
decentralized and difficult to censor
and and so forth but it's it's very it's
an ongoing debate it's gonna go on for a
long long time I don't think anything's
been settled and if we're headed into
another crypto bull market in the next
one two years we're gonna be having this
discussion even more because the coin
fees are going to get very expensive and
hopefully by that point the the
Lightning Network the this layer 2
protocol that I talked about is more
mature but we're just we're gonna have
to see what do you think is holding back
broader adoption of crypto currently of
all the things that might contribute to
it or that are thrown around what do you
think actually is holding back adoption
well I suppose when you when you say
adoption I think of people just getting
some that's where it starts and if if
the first phase of crypto becoming a
global payment network and store value
and
all these other sort of fantastic things
the first step is people actually
acquiring it and the only reason they
really acquire it right now is as a
speculative asset they're betting that
this adoption will happen that it'll be
more valuable in the future and so
naturally when when this market which I
mentioned is cyclical enters one of
these bull phases
that's when everyone's buying and
telling it that's when you have the cab
drivers telling you crypto tips and when
that's over then it's it's simply the
pendulum swinging the other way it's
almost it's almost like gravity so I
think that there are laws in economics
and even if we can't know them they
still exist and this is sort of one of
them that there's kind of a refractory
period where when everyone goes crazy
and mortgages their house and and buys a
bunch of Bitcoin and then the price
starts going down it's it's the opposite
of that people people selling the
Bitcoin people getting disillusioned and
so it's it's it's mainly just this just
these phases that we go through now over
time I do think that these bubbles will
become more attenuated I do think we're
gonna start to achieve something of a
relative stability in the price and
hopefully at a lot higher price but if
we're going there it's not going to be
in a straight line and there's gonna be
these fits and starts where the world
sort of wakes up and says oh wait no
Bitcoin is is magic Internet money and I
want some you know another piece and
maybe to answer your question more
directly is that I think the that that
larger external crises will have an
effect as well so in past bubbles
because there have been quite many
they've been sparked at least in part by
by financial crises in the news Cyprus
had an issue back in 2013 and that kind
of sparked this rally and a Bitcoin
where people thought oh well if Cyprus
is collapsing then maybe people want
Bitcoin and I think there will be more
crises we have crises in in Venezuela
right now although they they have
trouble getting getting Bitcoin cuz I'm
not sure who would sell it to them
but first world countries are not immune
to financial crises we learned that in a
very acute way back in 2008
and there will be more and thankfully
we'll have things like like Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency that in my opinion will
be seen as as safe havens I want to talk
a little bit about what what I think
what I believe is a relatively false
notion about Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies being used for illegal
transactions and I want to be like super
clear just so we're all on the same page
I have no idea logical attachment to it
being true or being untrue that
cryptocurrencies are more or less likely
to be used for illegal transactions I
just look at data points so to speak one
interesting one was when the Silk Road
was shut down it had effectively no
measurable impact on the amount of
Bitcoin transactions and money being
transacted and there was the belief up
or assertion up until that point at
least that a lot of Bitcoin was being
used for illegal transactions related to
Silk Road so that would be sort of like
one data point suggesting that that that
was not the case the other thing I sort
of think about and then I want to want
to hear what you think is that even if
Bitcoin is used for illegal transactions
so is cash so our credit cards often
through the use of gift card schemes
that you can look up on the internet and
and sort of learn a lot about so I think
you would still have to demonstrate that
it makes it easier and maybe it does so
let me turn it over to you there what do
we know about the connection between
cryptocurrency and criminal transactions
and what do you see as the primary
transaction types for which Bitcoin and
other large Kryptos are being used that
yeah that's been a stigma since the
early days yeah the there's a couple of
criticisms or accusations that are
levied the first is that people use it
to to hide activity right I'll briefly
make the case for financial privacy I
think that most people who who use
cryptocurrency in a private way are
doing so for their own protection I mean
the basic example I give is that you you
don't tell all your all your friends how
much money you have because they will
judge you and they'll they'll judge all
your future just
whether you know you buy a car or send
your kid to private school they'll think
he can't afford that oh he can you he's
so cheap there's almost no correct
answer when when disclosing disclosing
your net worth so people sort of
understand that instinctively but but
when someone else tries to hide their
their finances sometimes we we might
suspect that they're hiding something
more nefarious I I don't think that's
the case for the most part let me
comment that one just briefly because I
think there's an interesting analogy
there when we learned about NSA bulk
surveillance I was very critical of
people who said if you're not doing
anything wrong then what do you care I
thought that that was sort of a
logically unsound argument and in the
same way I think that wanting privacy
for financial transactions alone is not
really something to criticise or
indicative of wrongdoing it doesn't tell
us what crypto is being used for but I
think that there's an analogous bad
argument being made when people say if
you want privacy you must be doing
something wrong in the same way that's
saying if you're not doing anything
wrong who cares if the NSA knows every
email you're right yeah so we agree
there I won't I won't continue on that
point I think I think we're aligned on
that one yeah the the second thing I'd
say is yes criminals use cryptocurrency
but that's not an indictment of
cryptocurrency that's simply by nature
of it being a technology and a
disruptive technology you know you kind
of touched upon yes of criminals use
hundred-dollar bills as well this is
that argument cryptocurrency is a
technology like nuclear power is a
technology and nuclear power is a is in
its essence quite neutral it depends on
what you do is it you can either create
a power plant and light a bunch of homes
and make everybody happy or you can go
blow up a city so it really has to do
with with the actors and their
intentions criminals also use cell
phones and they wear shoes there's
there's very little
yeah there's very little to grasp on to
when you're saying that just because
cryptocurrency is a tool and that some
people can use it for illegal purposes
therefore crypto is bad yeah it's
actually the it's the ad hominem genetic
fallacy which is
Hitler breathed oxygen you you breathe
oxygen also I mean it's effectively that
Hitler had a dog therefore you know all
dog owners or all dogs are bad or
something like that good so as far as
how governments tax or regulate
cryptocurrency I mean without getting
into too many sort of like specific
examples of things that individual
countries may have done correctly or
incorrectly at a more sort of general
level is government catching up on how
to deal with crypto transactions are
some governments catching up and others
are not and is this going to be a factor
that influences adoption as well it is
so yes in both cases it they are
catching up one tangible example of that
is the fight between the IRS and
coinbase
where they wanted basically all of coin
bases records so they could go compare
those records to the tax filings of
their their customers coinbase fought
back and I believe it just ended up
being a subset people who bought or sold
above a certain amount it's going to be
a game of cat and mouse for a while
frankly I don't think that
cryptocurrency is the best way to
launder money or avoid taxes although if
it were and maybe if the government
needed to appeal to its citizens versus
demanding the taxes maybe that would be
a good thing sort of an interesting
thought experiment if if it's if it's
harder for the government to collect
taxes and maybe maybe something with
change in in the way that they do so and
lastly I'd say that there are lots of
ways to shelter shelter your income from
cryptocurrency sales so just to be clear
in the US if you buy Bitcoin at a dollar
and you don't and it's worth $5,000 or
5300 as it is right now you don't owe
any taxes until you sell that that
Bitcoin it's that's not it's not a tax
though they're unrealized gains similar
to if you buy some stock at a low price
and it goes up you have unrealized gains
there but it's not a taxable event until
you realize those gains precisely but
but even if you were to sell them there
are there are different vehicles
available to you to either defer or
shelter this income so in my case I
actually did sell some Bitcoin last year
and I rolled the gains into what's
called an opportunity zone fund so this
might be a little financial tip for your
viewers if they have some sudden
realized gains it doesn't just apply to
crypto anything else and the the gains
are deferred for ten years and then any
gains on that investment it's a real
estate investment after that or tax rate
and I I'd say a normal average person
like myself with two kids and a wife in
a house who's not really looking for
trouble with the IRS still has a lot
that they can do on a personal level
without without breaking the law or
becoming a felon so Aaron let's talk a
little bit about BRD wallet I mean first
of all what is it what does it do what
problem are you looking to solve sure
so BRD you can probably tell I work for
BRD I've got a few icons around here BRD
it very simply it's one of the oldest
and largest cryptocurrency wallets in
the world we have over two million
customers and I think over 180 countries
it is simple and easy to use for
newcomers it's what people use to
introduce their their grandma to Bitcoin
at the Thanksgiving dinner table it
lives as an app on your iPhone and your
Android as a safe place to store send
and receive cryptocurrency nobody but
you has access or visibility into your
funds or transactions meaning BRD
doesn't even know the names of its
customers so if you have an issue with
the way Facebook is using your data and
monetizing it without your your
permission or or blessing think about a
company like BRD that literally doesn't
even have any data on its customers in
the first place
we also offer additional services such
as buying selling or trading of
cryptocurrencies these are provided by
partnerships but seamlessly integrated
into the app one of the interesting
things and I think there's probably an
entire other conversation about
passwords in general one of the really
interesting things is that you don't
have a login or a password when you use
your platform you connect using a twelve
word key if one does not know a lot
about passwords and cryptography that
might not sound super secure but can you
give us the the the sort of mathematical
or logistical explanation as to why it
is very secure yeah it's it's pretty
mind-blowing so if you were to take so
this these
twelve words this sort of root password
if you will each each slot has I think
it's 2048 available words so there's a
word list and then it's one of these two
thousand words for each slot now if you
ask a computer to crack a one-word
password that's two thousand words
possibility it's going to take a
fraction of a fraction of a second so it
is with two words or three words or four
words but when you get to twelve words
you're looking at crazy numbers such as
if we turn if we took all the matter in
our solar system and turn it into a
supercomputer a thousand times as
efficient as the best computer we have
today and let it run until the heat
death of the universe it still would not
crack your password so we get into some
really astronomical numbers that are
almost impossible to comprehend but the
short the short version is it's secure
yeah I mean it's sort of the idea of if
you take a penny and you double it every
day for a while that doubling does not
have that significant of an impact on
how much money you have but at the end
of a month you're all of a sudden
talking about a huge amount of money
that's a perfect that's a perfect
analogy it's exactly the same we've been
speaking with Aaron Lasher who is the
chief strategy officer at BRD you can
find out more about BRD by using the
link down in the video description and
you can always get in touch with me
about what you want to hear about
related to cryptocurrency blockchain
technology and the like Aaron really
really great to have you on today thanks
so much David